i didn't know a lot about new zealand
i remember at school we learned a lot
about australia but not new zealand and
so when i met my husband it was actually
quite funny because i was introducing
him to one of my friends and i said i
said to my friend i said oh
it's from new zealand you know the
island of australia and it was like no
it's not it's a country on its own i was
like oh gosh sorry but yeah he did not
like that
but i remember
if i could put it just
simply
it was very very stressful
but also very exciting because i didn't
know much about it and i was excited to
come and
learn
but also not knowing the stress that it
was going to put on myself you know
coming to a different country and the
culture everything was so different